quali popit potrei aggiungere
[Musica]
lungo
chi vincerà la sfida di oggi
no
oggi nuova challenge nel rapporto vivere
tutto questo video raggiungere gli
undici cui non vi piace tuttora un'altra
sala
grazie
questo video raggiunge i giudici
milanesi
intanto proprio i 13 challenge forlì
soldi portato fatevi vedere te ne sarai
tu dimmi la challenge di oggi però sarà
un po diversa però che proprio due
miliardi da bendati qui dovremo decidere
se accettare un grosso bendati base al
suolo infatti da nessuno possiamo capire
se ci sono tanti profitto pochi fox sarà
tutto divertente come sempre voi alla
fine dovrete decidere se vinco io ho
visto evitare mettetevi comodi prendete
i pop corn e iniziamo primo round
questo
the cave di più non è offerto niente mi
devi venire qualcosa di scambio che io
non so però che cos'è che ti bendata
dentro c'è allora aspetta che prendo
qualcosa io ti offro questo
[Musica]
è
accaduto
come mai a sapere che è caduto martedì
bendato ho sentito i rumori per terra o
no mi sto andando perfino
qualcos'altro aspettati ho promesso
a
mosca che l'ha fondata
[Musica]
bobbit che si illumina al buio vero in
un cassetto che a bollire e quando vuoi
e stato un buon lo scambio per me oppure
no cerchiamo uno scambio per vitale
questa volta ti offro resto
e tu che cosa mi offri cambio del suono
non mi sembrava niente di bello anzi
sembrava molto leggero quindi io ti
offro questo qui
vedi che sono che ha fatto accetti
guarda in base al suono io dico di più
soffro anche io
ho già aperto due bobbit ti offro anche
questo che è molto grande e dai accetta
trascorro di più basta mi sono scocciata
secondo me non è offerto un buon pop hit
e te ne stai approfittando stai
prendendo un sacco di bobbit quindi
[Musica]
ok posso togliere la benda e
cosa
no
no no mi dispiace per te così impari
dovevi accettare prima e adesso me lo
tengo io questo pronto
a vuoto dai principi
no no no no ormai è troppo tardi ai già
rifiutato quindi niente tiene i tuoi
post it e io mi tengo il mio
terzo round
pronti via e vai
cosa vi offre ho sentito un sogno di
tanti pop hit
questo mi sembrava solo uno però no era
pio di euro ma io sono offerti di più io
ti offro anche
questo questo se tutto questo
sembrava uno più grande e uno più
piccolo di più aspetta devo pensarci un
momento
[Musica]
sto pensando
quali pop hit potrei aggiungere
[Musica]
secondo me i tuoi poppins sono molto
interessanti
quindi aggiungo
altri
azzurro pitt
allora
accetti
finanziato gioco certo
che cosa fitto
[Musica]
ma noi se ti sono più grande è uno che
piccolo hai sentito male non solo tre
minibus
uccidendo in lama che
adoro la cucina e la rosa e lava
multicolor tutti per me nino demo di
questo scambio non sono molto contento
ciò la sagra mi piace il cupcake di
plastica che non posso mangiare il
fantasmino paura per te per gustare
meglio
marsala o quinto round nominare abbiamo
fatto al pinto io ti
aspetta aspetta
denti che d'oro
certo mi offri questo mi sembrava grate
allora ti offro vediamo degli inti offro
testo piuttosto e poi credo che
aggiungerò anche questo
no non puoi non accettare l'offerta
tantissime sono offerti tanti ok allora
però anche questo mi sembrava piccolino
di più
questa è l'ultima e nun tene offrirò più
questa cosa perché anno ed era l'altro
devo pensarci un momento come devi
pensarci un momento di un'offerta di 250
secondo me non sono tanti sono tanti
permessi un sacco e tu solo uno io ho
capito che non è offerto uno gigante
però aiutano offerti tantissimi dai non
è che poi approfittatene così non mi va
bene effetti mi sembra che i miei
offerto tanti bobby
no non è possibile
io ho sentito
[Applauso]
[Musica]
è
stato fatto da offrirti tutti questi
persone quello lì ti sarai sbagliato no
io ho sentito un rumore in gigante non è
possibile che questo abbia fatto tutto
quel rumore lo appoggiato molto forte ho
fatto
vedi sembra molto pesante a 1 che ha
svelato il mio trucco
questo non è giusto dammi la mia nalesso
ho perso tutti freebox
trovo bene a questa volta le numero
troppi danni la principessa vitale
attenzione attenzione e ti offro questo
è
questo che pitanti questi po perire
adesso tu che cosa mi offri che pesanti
questi pochi si devono essere belli
grandi a meno che non sta aiutando la
mia stessa tecnica
chi lo sa
ti offro
questo
questo e
4 allora accetti non puoi rifiutare 4
meno e offerti allora mi sa che questa
volta capito di più chi sul degrado di
più buffa di più ma quanto saranno belli
e rari allora hip hop it che hai offerto
bene ti ha offerto una montagna di poppy
tu non puoi rifiutare allora accetti
quindi mai messi altri quattro anzi ne
aggiungo altri
un altro e poi
mi sa che ne aggiungo un altro ancora e
un altro ancora 11 12
13 soci ma scusa non è che premuto il
pulsante più e tu mi stai offrendo così
ecco fatto ma si sa pure che non voglio
fermare altre no mi sembrano già
tantissimi successo cetto ok
rivelazione 32
non vuole fragola
belli dovevano essere 14 invece sono
solo quattro pezzo che è contato male
hai perso il conto ma no io ho sentito
il rumore che voleva tu
hai anche detto che le offre di più per
il futuro del nostro di più è anche un
altro e un altro secondo me ti sei
sbagliato come rosa qualcosa di strano
io ho sentito chiaramente 14 volte
rumore no è solo che stai perdendo i
partiti non
basta o la collezione di arrivasse la
vita nell'amore tiziana
ultimo round
allora questa volta ti offro
io ti offro
cosa offre
no di più
di più
[Musica]
questa forse sembrava più grande e poi
questo accetti rumori non erano super
poppins
vedere un'altra proprietà tra offre di
più e volere stanno finendo i miei pop
eater minima di due travi quelli che ho
vinto da terzi
rivoglio indietro allora dico che stiamo
basta non ho più puppet di new di più di
più
aspetta devo pensare a quale bobbit
offrirti magari quelli che ho vinto oggi
si si hai detto oggi siamo indietro beh
ti bastano di più di più di chi li
voglio tutti quelli che ho perso oggi
liquido tutti indietro beh io ho rimesso
tutti quelli che ho finto oggi quindi
devi far posto a cercare per quel pop
hit gigante male mai seduti tutti è
certo che li ho messi tutti è
praticamente sono tutti pop hit che ho
vinto oggi
sono tutti quindi devi accettare dai
accetta tutti i pochi che ho vinto per
pochi gigante degli esperta come fai a
sapere che c'è un po pitt gigante
che cosa stai bando senza avventa
momento per controllare che il detenuto
a tripoli che tu non lo sono tutti può
piccoli
tesori profit che ho perso oggi sono qui
non in ferro tu stavi barando senza
benda ceco sa healy sulle ginocchia è
[Musica]
il pop hit che volevo
e
non ci posso credere che ha imparato è
tolto con pure la band a guardare
siccome tu hai barato adesso ve li
riprendo tutti i gesti
peggio per te è già forte così bari a
non barare
aspetta ieri lasciava la società
come sono navona se non posso restare
sul tecnico che è un pope to die rida
mimì almeno nemmeno quelli piccoli e va
bene so io quale ridarti allora tieni
tu
sì questa è la punizione per aver barato
ti tieni tutte le ananas adesso no a
ridarmi miei no pianeti leana ma se
cambiano piacciono
aiuti che vi rimandiamo rifare la
challenge subito ma no mi dispiace per
dover te che hai imparato ragazzi
lasciate un mi piace arriviamo subito a
12 mila mi piace devo recuperare un po
di bob it non posso rimanere il salto
alza iscrivetevi i commenti come
dovrebbe essere la prossima challenge se
bendati o in qualche altra modalità
scrivetecelo nei commenti mi
raccomandano estate mi piazzo poi è
stato secondo voi il momento più
divertente questa challenge secondo me
quello che a me è piaciuto di più è
stato quando ho scoperto la vita mi
stavo pregando tutti i botti plico
domando momento più divertente è stato
quando ti ho offerto un sacco di ananas
ma ora sono tornate a me
lasciate un mi piace e ora vi lasciamo
con quattro casi limite cui cliccare per
vedere i nostri altri video cliccate su
quella che preferite una visione ciao